so I'm single I'm super [ __ ] single
I've always been single oh I'm very
single you're single oh yeah you're
single I'm very single how am Jack and
I'm single as [ __ ] when you're single
you use online dating when you use
online dating you need a good profile
but for some reason my current profile
isn't getting me any good dates so I
talked to OkCupid co-founder Christian
rudder to find out what I'm doing wrong
I think you're actually you're text is
really good but if you know what we've
done experiments your profile sex is
something like 8 percent of what people
take away the picture being the other
92% so really like it would be better to
spend an hour doing a photo shoot than
it would be to spend an hour writing my
profile yeah better to spend an hour
doing a photo shoot than to spend 10
hours on your profile so that's exactly
what I did but I knew I couldn't do this
alone so I sought out the sexiest man I
could think of this is Brock he has over
1.4 million followers on Instagram and
if you don't know why I mean just look
at him how's it going you take
incredible photos thank you dare I say
sexy photos it's more about just what
looks good in the moment you know so
most of my pictures are honestly you
take one shot right on the spot and I
like oh that's cool that's it let's go
the reason I brought you here Brock is
because I don't know how to take a sexy
picture okay do you think that you can
help me 100% let's look for some spots
yeah and check it out we want something
a little more even in the background for
the shot cuz you're gonna be the main
focus and I don't want anything too
distracting in the background you're the
folks so first photo what are we doing
first one I think we should do the shirt
open yeah so I had my hair back like
that and you're just a little turn so
I'm gonna shoot a couple of these so we
can compare I've never had a reason to
go like this do a little stretch out
right there Lou you ever do the prune
trick like
prune I've never heard of that never
heard of the palm tree never heard of I
got things to teach you
second photo what are we thinking I'm
thinking the pool shot classic pose oh
it's cold like to be sexy yeah I'd be
willing to get a little wet am i right
some screens bleeding into my eyes
that's sexy this is a little bit how do
you be natural do you feel comfortable
in that trick right now how I say switch
it I'm confident with who I am you know
and it took me a long time to get to
that point from when I was younger and
you were you were an awkward teenager oh
yeah
might have been as awkward and skinny
and lanky as you could have got how do
you feel right now
really stiff and uncomfortable let's try
more not to copy the exact photo yeah
let's do what makes you feel comfortable
being happy and confident with who you
are it shows for the camera right there
just naturally just thinking just bring
that inner self that you have out that
was actually good yeah yeah check it out
that's what you're going for it's
something that's so great to it because
we're all so different there's so many
different people in the world you can't
just say that there's one
one-size-fits-all you know I'm sexy in
ways that you're not sexy 100% 100% no
oh yeah I'm a little bit jealous I'm
like look at this on my damn Zak right
like sighs the couple bros taking
selfies in a bit crushing it man
crashing now I'm like bad boy and put
somebody through that feels like my
natural sexy impulses come on signals
from you pretty soon man if anything you
have at least one fan here no matter
what I got you
holy [ __ ] Brock am i already sexy you
are did I come in here already sexy you
did you just didn't realize it yet you
just have to brush it off just a little
dust right there right there I'm sexy
yep I didn't need you at all
I mean I don't know wouldn't go that far
sexy now ahh
looking back I did a pretty decent job
at recreating Brock's photos but roxrite
I shouldn't try and be sexy the Brock
way I need to learn to accept being sexy
the Zach way and the moments when I
wasn't trying just the normal photos
those are the profile pictures that will
hopefully get me the date that I want
also I threw in a shirtless photo of
rocking me together in bed because you
know can hurt it is so uncomfortably hot
right it is hot I don't know if yourself
I'm sweating I'm sweating I unless y'all
I feel like I'm sweating more than yours
like I look like I'm sweating more than
you're sweating I don't know it's like
they're sweating more tell us tell us
what